I'm Jonathan Friedland from the
Guardian.
And great pleasure to be moderating or
chairing perhaps is more appropriate
word.
Um,
our speakers and our debate for tonight,
as you know,
the motion before us is the best chance
for peace between Israel and Palestine
is for Uncle Sam to butt out and
American colloquialism.
Uh,
despite this being a intelligence
squared in London and so much has been
going on in the whole,
the wider Middle East across the Arab
world in particular,
the so called Arab spring,
the Arab awakening,
depending on how you prefer to call it,
that people on both sides of the Israel
Palestine conflict,
uh,
who said some might accuse of being
almost addicted to the attention of the
world have been slightly feeling left
out in recent months.
Um,
because the,
uh,
attention has moved away,
nevertheless,
that conflict does still go on.
Um,
and it's that one very particular aspect
of it that we want to explore tonight.
We are going to be doing something
different in this debate from some
debates on this conflict that you may
have heard before.
And it's different in this sense.
We're not aiming for perhaps sometimes
what can be accrued debate which pits
Israelis against Palestinians or even
friends of Israel against friends of the
Palestinians.
Uh,
rather,
all four speakers tonight would insist
that they are looking for solutions for
indeed resolution rather than simply
defending one side or the other.
Nevertheless,
within that framework or within that
context,
uh,
there are,
um,
we will hope they are revealed tonight
substantial disagreements between them
about how best to achieve that,
uh,
resolution.
Uh,
they are for people who are in their own
different ways,
dedicate much of their professional
lives to wrestling with this subject and
they do it with huge commitment.
Um,
so I think we're very,
very lucky to have them and I'm going to
introduce them all one by one as they
come up to speak.
But first of all,
I just want to,
um,
mention something that you will have
been doing,
uh,
already,
which is costing your pre vote.
I'm going to give you the result of
that.
The vote that you walked in with the
vote before,
you'd had a chance to be swayed by the
almost scissor Romanian rhetoric that is
going to be unleashed,
uh,
from this panel.
Um,
but there will be,
you will cost a final vote later on.
And the way that works is you'll have
one of these cards if you want to vote
for you,
tear off the four bit.
If you want to bet against you,
turn off the against bit.
And if you are an abstention,
you slipped the entire card into a
ballot box,
almost Vladimir Putin,
esc,
where method of voting.
Um,
but we're going to have a very proper in
democratic result,
uh,
beef,
in contrast to their IPAD apps.
Um,
so we're going to do that.
Uh,
that's the format and uh,
the rest of it,
I'm going to explain more or less as we
go on.
There is a little new twist in the
intelligence squared format,
which I hope you're going to enjoy it.
Uh,
which we'll come to later.